with this ever-expanding selection of
films Netflix has plenty of
psychological thrillers that are perfect
for movie night but it's time to look
beyond popular films like bird box and
no country for old men here are a few
disturbing films you probably haven't
seen but though watch them alone
in the good neighbor we immediately
learn that the supposed haunting of
Howard grainy played by James Caan has
been orchestrated by his two tech-savvy
teenage neighbors Sean and Ethan but
that doesn't make the situation any less
terrifying with the proper execution it
is possible to drive an unsuspecting
person into believing that they are
truly being haunted Sean has his
reservations about the whole scheme but
Ethan is clearly on a mission but this
guy getting the reclusive old man to
believe he's being haunted as more than
just a prank the reason he's tormenting
grainy is far darker than that and the
consequences turned out to be deadly
grainy handles are strange occurrences
in his home surprisingly well until
Ethernet collate his efforts and pushes
him over the brink this interesting take
on the found-footage genre serves as a
warning about the many pitfalls of
revenge he's looking at us
simply puts the good neighbor is one of
the most intense realist Netflix has to
offer right now
brick might not be as well-known as
Joseph gordon-levitt's other films but
there's a reason it's become a cult
favorite in this twisty mystery
gordon-levitt portrays Brendan friar a
lonely teenager who recently went
through a breakup with his ex-girlfriend
Emily played by Emily Dara Venn of lusts
Fame when Brendan finds a note directing
him to a payphone he's already in way
over his head
Emily winds up dead and Brendan starts
working his way through a mystery that
involves a muscle-bound bully a
high-school drug kingpin heard a few
seemingly random words that serve as
cryptic clues to Emily's fates needless
to say it's all very hard-boiled for our
fifty fish to Blancas the ink blotter on
the desk in the den and the basement of
the house with attacking mailbox
directed by Rian Johnson brig pays
homage to classic detective films but
the plots and characters are still
distinctly modern although gordon-levitt
uh certainly appeared in bigger
blockbusters it'd be a real shame to
overlook break with its clever plotting
rapid-fire dialogue and sly references
to film noir classics this psychological
thriller is definitely worth
investigating what's scarier than
suddenly discovering there's an
uninvited guest in your house we've seen
his plot play out in horror films a
million times before but we've never
seen a film approach supremists away
that hush does Kate Siegel plays muddy a
deaf-mute woman who lost her ability to
hear and speak as a teenager these days
she lives alone in an isolated cabin in
the woods however her quiet life takes a
turn for the terrifying when a masked
intruder begins to prey upon her
[Music]
but he realizes Maddy can tear the
Psychopaths uses his newfound knowledge
to torment his new victim
and what follows is a fiendish game of
cat and mouse are simply won't let up
Hirsch is a serious nail-biter that's
decidedly not for the faint of heart
the found footage film creep is indeed a
full-fledged creep show and it comes
highly recommended
the story begins innocently enough for a
protagonist Aaron the videographer is
heading out to meet a new clients named
Joseph who wants to create a series of
videos for his unborn son Joseph tells
Aaron that he's dying of cancer but he
wants his son to have a way of getting
to know his father
but as Joseph's behavior becomes
stranger and more concerning Herron has
a stronger ch to flee after all Joseph
stories aren't adding up and Darrin is
worried for his own safety but Joseph
estat sermons keep tabs on our and when
the videographer runs he quickly
discovers that he can't really hide from
this full-fledged psycho let me go and
if you're looking for a truly chilling
Netflix and chill experience
you're in luck in 2017 the sequel creep
2 was released and it's also streaming
on Netflix
double the derangement in backtrack
Adrien Brody plays Peter Brauer a
psychotherapist who's starting to
realizes something strange about his
clients like a seriously strange
meanwhile Peter is suffering recurring
nightmares and depressive episodes due
to the death of his daughter eventually
he comes to a somewhat startling
revelation all of his clients are dead
if only had picked up on the subtle sign
sooner
Pisa begins to research who his clients
were when they were alive and eventually
discovers they all live near a specific
train line one that happened to
regularly pass right through his
hometown
now Peter must retrace his steps by
going back home seeking out some
familiar faces and trying to understand
why he's at the center of a haunting
backtrack is a journey through Peters
murky memory as he struggles to figure
out how to make things right between his
past and his present this psychological
thriller serves as a strong reminder
that Adrien Brody is a singular talent
but he turns in an absolutely fantastic
performance here check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite
thrillers are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]